[Music]  that the best you've got extraordinary  reports coming out of the Soviet Union  tales of a bee with powers and abilities  far beyond those of mortal men as I said  mr. president of course I understand  your concern but I assure you the Luthor  company has this under control I don't  blame those among you that fear me or  you been taught to fear all your lives  this is a world where the strong rule  and you are the strongest all of us it  is only a matter of time very little  time until all of Western Europe is  absorbed is taken by the Soviet Superman  look alive lanterns we've got it covered  I'm honored to have you here ambassador  call me Diana and what should I call you  Superman  you think you're going to stop me back  me  what now  now I saved the world  [Music]